hi I'm Eric Foss and episode 2 of Game
of Thrones final season reminded us that
in the face of oblivion nothing warms a
heart quite like romance like Aria
showing entry that the real staff she
wanted was his and tormund Giantsbane
'he's love of giant milk making us all
suddenly lactose-intolerant welcome back
to another in-depth scene by scene
analysis filled with hidden means and
connections the subtle details to
satisfy that inner child who watches TV
shows the way brand watches people's
souls by the way we really got to talk
about that inner child he's scaring the
other inner children spoiler mourning if
you haven't watched the episode yet and
let's dive deep starting with some
miserable updates to the opening credits
check out my other breakdown to the new
season 8 opening credits but this
sequence includes updates of the
flipping blue tiles represent the White
Walkers progress having advanced further
beyond last hearth which by the way
takes the shape of a spiral to reflect
how the night King arranged the dead Ned
umber in a spiral of shrimp cocktail
severed limbs these episode two credits
also show the new fortifications being
constructed around Winterfell among them
is a pit of fire that encircles the
castle the opening image shows Jaime
Lannister standing trial upon his return
of Winterfell but not on trial for the
crime that we expected Daenerys brings
up her brother Viserys and their anger
toward the Kingslayer who killed their
father the Mad King when Danny returned
to Westeros in season 7 her costume was
updated to a black and crimson palette
that was meant as a reference to the
Wardrobe of her late brother who dreamt
of invading Westeros with the Dothraki
Army and Dragons in recent episodes Dany
switched to lighter gray fur as a way to
show her trying to win the North's
loyalty and yeah to stay warm but now as
a judge of this Kingslayer trial her fur
appears darker with the crimson streaks
really coming out to once again reflect
Targaryen wrath over the throne that was
in her eyes stolen from her and her
brother by Jaime when Jaime confirmed
Cersei troops are not coming Tyrion is
now in the hot seat as Danny's angry
gaze redirects on him Varys curiously
leans his bald head over Tyrion
shoulders are gonna bear look at Danny
publicly scolding the hand after Tyrians
many mistakes he's feeling the heat of
other potential advisers angling to
replace him as hand of the Queen
polluting Varys
Jaime refuses to apologize for killing
the Mad King or for attacking Ned Stark
landing snapping everything I did I did
for my house and my family I'd do it all
again brand having finally found someone
to wheel him inside chimes in the things
we do for love that's the kind of
firebrand to consider spitting at the
night King brand is of course calling
back Jamie's words from the first
episode things I do for love and
throwing this famous quote back in
Jamie's face rouse him just like quoting
cast as a ladder what's the little
finger in the way it ruined his life
okay Jamie's passion self-defense
echoes his anger over Ned Stark's
judgment that he shared with Brienne
back in season three and it's Brienne
who now steps in to defend Jamie
literally standing in between Jamie and
his potential executioner's just like
how Jamie shielded her during her
deadliest trial against the bear Brienne
recalls Jamie defending her from Vargo
hOAT and his whole rapey band of bloody
mummers which cost Jamie's hand and she
brings up the oath that he kept to
sonses mother Catelyn to send Brienne to
keep Sansa alive this oath was the
namesake of Brienne sword Oathkeeper
this episode is titled
a night of the Seven Kingdoms which
Jamie later anoints Brienne as but more
broadly the term applies to several
nights this episode chief among them
Jamie Lannister as the central character
of this hour his loyalties as a knight
are on trial here he broke his sacred
vows by killing Danny's father and now
you must prove that he's no longer a
knight for just House Lannister but a
knight fighting for all of mankind the
side-eye is again full of hidden subtext
when Sansa forgives Jaime the focus
suddenly shifts to Daenerys in the
background staring daggers at Sansa last
episode used this same exact focus shift
when Danny looked over at Sansa and
warned her that a dragons will eat
whatever they want this is the beginning
of Daenerys downward spiral of authority
and influence this episode hopefully
it's not the kind of spiral that Ned
umber found himself in Daenerys
chastises Tyrion for his repeated
failures snapping says he still sits on
the throne if you can't help me take it
back
I'll find another hand who can and
before huffing off Danny briefly looks
up at Jorah
Jorah and Varys are positioned directly
behind Tyrion reflecting the exact line
of succession for hand to the Queen
should Danny ever else Tyrion these
other two suitors are literally way
line my queen wait talk to me I
understand you
I think Tyrion strategic blunders are
actually setting them up for a major
victory in the wars to come more on that
later down in the forges REO watch his
ginjury with a glint of fascination not
unlike her curious glances at him back
at Harrenhal in season 2 Aria questions
ginjury about his experience with the
white walkers asking his killcount and
how they move but he cuts her off she's
- you want to know what they're like
death that's what they like and ru
response battering some dragonglass
spear heads and the wall I know death
he's got many faces I look forward to
seeing this one Aria is echoing her
experience with the faceless men who
worship the many-faced God in arias
precision which she also shows off with
her archery later on is a callback to
her showing up brand in the pilot
episode bran meets Jamie in the godswood
3 and Jamie from the guilt of crippling
him saying that the push was to a
pivotal moment and both their destinies
that Jamie would still be a selfish
piece of crap if he hadn't pushed brand
and bran would still be Brandon stark
instead of in his words something else
now something else as in a tree on
wheels this is a noble lie kept by bran
to hide the truth about Jamie in order
to spare their people further chaos and
self-destruction
but Branson's off Jamie with a cryptic
warning how do you know there is enough
twit yes I am something else a wet
blanket what exactly brand knows about
the future is a mystery because in the
past he has said that it's visions come
to him in fragments like pieces of a
puzzle
but here he's suggesting that they could
lose this coming battle perhaps
fulfilling the doom filled imagery of
the preseason aftermath teaser which
included Jamie's hand in the snow
without Jamie Jamie joins Tyrion to
observe the preparations including the
construction of wooden caltrops caltrops
our defensive structures used as far
back as the Romans to protect against
cavalry charges and chariots but this
kind of structure has been used for
several generations throughout history
modern examples including the concrete
Czech hedgehogs that line the beaches of
Normandy here they're covering the wood
with dragonglass spikes I assume to
force swarming weights and white walkers
into the same spikes cover the castle
battlements and logs that they can use
to swing down and
wipeouts swarming zombie whites much
like the Nights Watch used against the
wildlings in season four
Tyrion waxes poetic by talking about his
dick again telling Jaime I always
pictured myself dying in my own bed the
age of 80 the belly full of wine and a
girl's mouth around my [ __ ] Jamie
actually finishes the sentence meaning
that this must have been the thing
Tyrion needs to say a lot we did hear
say this exact thing to Shagga back in
season one how would you like to die
Tyrion son of Tywin my own bed at the
age of 80 with a bellyful of wine and a
girl's mouth around my [ __ ]
but then Tyrion goes into a more
interesting idea about Cersei maybe
often I'm dead marched down to King's
Landing and Vitara thought mmm
this isn't the first time Tyrion
actually wished harm to his sister
remember back in season two after she
hurt Roz he didn't take it well
promising I will hurt you for this the
day will come when you think you're safe
and happy and your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth and you will know
the debt is paid if Tyrion ends up being
the one to kill Cersei that would
fulfill the valonqar prophecy from the
books which that witch foretold that
Cersei would die at the hands of the von
Kahr the Valyrian word for a younger
brother theorists have interpreted that
to mean Jaime but it could also refer to
Tyrion outside soldiers dig trenches and
filled them with sharpened pikes grey
worm and other unsullied rigged up a
trap collapsible bridge now we saw these
trenches in the opening credits so part
of their defensive measures appears to
be a moat of fire trapping any invading
white zombie on the flaming pikes
thinning this line down to just the
White Walkers themselves where I presume
that they hope that all that dragon
class will come in handy Jaime confesses
to Brienne that he's not the fighter he
used to be and wishes to serve under her
command Jamie's feeling of inadequacy
comes from his missing sword hand of
course but also from the fact that his
sword is mere one-half of a whole he
carries widow's wail Joffrey's old sword
which along with Brienne sword
Oathkeeper which used to belong to Jaime
were both formerly the same sword Ned
Stark's Valyrian steel sword ice Brianna
and Jaime's unity as a fighting force
feels like the reforging of ice and Ned
Stark's legacy of Honor
living on through these characters Sir
Jorah another honorable Knight the Seven
Kingdoms this episode counsels Daenerys
to forgive Tyrion and to make peace with
Sansa
Sansa shares the concerns that Dany is
manipulating John saying men do stupid
things for women she's alluding to her
brother Robb who married to Lisa instead
of honoring his deal with Walder Frey
she's worried that jon is also being
blinded by love another example of Sansa
invoking her mother's caution but then
salsa wanders about after this war
apparently not hearing the three eyed
buzzkill warning about this afterward
talk what about the north it was taken
from us we took it back and we said we'd
never bow to anyone else again what
about the north and the hand-holding
stops actually when a maester comes in
Sansa discreetly slides her hands off
the table all together as if taking this
whole fleeting friendship off the table
because this dragon Queen once sausage
to forget about her definitive victory
over the Bolton's which Sansa reminds us
with this loving embrace of Theon who
escaped with her from the Bolton's in
season six
another honorable knight sir Davos meets
this feisty girl with a burn scar on her
cheek reminding him of Shireen Baratheon
unfortunate daughter of Stannis
Baratheon who taught him how to read and
whose face was scarred with greyscale
and yeah got burned alive composed of
Ramin Djawadi even snuck in a subtle
music you with Shireen steam as this
girl talks I won't fight too
[Music]
together like that it sounds like egg
types of the whole book Davos and Gilly
convinced this little badass to defend
the Crypt which this episode states no
less than six times is the safest place
in Winterfell yeah that can't be a good
sign the White Walkers resurrect corpses
people so what's to stop them from
raising the corpses in the Winterfell
crypts now sure some of you say most of
the Stark ancestors are bones at this
point but I'll remind you that many of
the white zombies don't appear to be
much more than skeletons and in the
teaser for next week there was this
interesting life of Daenerys the dead
are already here as in downstairs where
most of the vulnerable people are
hanging out in they're not at all safe
zone
yikes so Sansa Gilly or baby Varys and
Shireen 2.0 might have a more terrifying
fight on their hands than they expected
hopefully this little girl won't turn
into a white because I don't want to see
ser Davos have to set her on fire moving
on to this war council meeting which
contains probably the most hidden clues
of this episode the shoulder it's
actually hinted that these battle plans
are intended to be assumptions of what
will happen just to set up next episode
that say a big fu to those expectations
John outlines their strategy the night
king made them all they follow his
command he falls to him maybe our best
Jones so John is building on the detail
he learned from last season during his
mission north of the wall when he killed
a white Walker and all the whites under
that White Walkers command disintegrated
as well the night King was the first
white Walker patient zero of this whole
race in addition to resurrecting
thousands of white corpses for his army
he created the white Walker generals in
his own image by transforming babies so
John is assuming that the white Walker
changed structure extends from foot
soldier to the general level to the
general to the night king level as well
so that killing the night king is like
striking at the heart or the brain and
causing the whole army of the dead body
to fall apart but we don't know if this
assumption is accurate like John's been
wrong before but bran introduces an
interesting twist shocking everyone in
the room that this potted plant can
actually talk he'll come for me he's
tried to so many times with many
three-eyed Ravens bran explains what he
believes the night King truly wants an
endless night to erase this world and
its memory bran is suggesting that the
three
Raven is the living history of Westeros
a courtroom stenographer who never
blinks we're not entirely sure of the
three-eyed Ravens origin whether he was
created by the children in the forest as
their club historian or if the
three-eyed raven is the result of the
old gods speaking through the weirwood
trees through a succession of human
spokespeople to protect the world from
destruction in either case this
knowledge is power
making the three-eyed raven the ultimate
threat to the night King Sam elaborates
saying House what death is isn't it
forgetting being forgotten if we forget
where we've been and what we've done
we're not men anymore just animals yeah
Sam is a history nerd in the comments
saying um isn't this just Chairman Mao
in his for olds all over again me yeah
that's that's me and you know what Sam's
right knowledge of history has always
been the deadliest tool for these
characters whether it's Ned Stark
studying the royal lineage to learn the
Lannister conspiracy or Sam learning
about Jon's true lineage from stolen
library books he was right to brag about
that bran and Sam are revoking that
expression that you might have heard
where we all die twice once when we take
our last breaths and again when someone
mentions our name for the final time the
quote is credited to Banksy but it's
actually a concept by Irvin yellow who
said someone very old is the last living
individual to have known some person or
cluster of people when that person dies
the whole cluster dies too vanishes from
the living memory I wonder who that
person will be for me
whose death will make me truly dead so
in the same way that this human cluster
is concerned with protecting their
existence
through an ancient memory link so too
are the White Walkers with the night
Kings death meaning the eraser in the
death of the pol cluster of White
Walkers bran shows them the night Kings
mark which she received back in season
six when bran - on the three-eyed Raven
roll that mark was kind of a magical
homing beacon for the night King to find
them under the great weirwood tree and
now bran believes that the night king is
returning to finish the job and he plans
to lure him in as bait in the godswood
but the truth is brands always trying to
get outside he needs the sunlight to
help with his photosynthesis this
explains John's tactic to keep Daenerys
his dragons closer to the Winterfell
godswood when to be honest them
unleashing fire on the full army of the
dead would be a lot more useful see Jon
assumes that the night king of
Arion will aim for bran in the godswood
and he wants the dragons to be waiting
close by hoping that killing the night
King will Domino the rest of the army
the map on the table shows the rest of
their battle plan and even though the
soldiers are focused northward the rest
of the castle is surrounded by a pike
trench which they plan to light ablaze
so rather than send the Dragons out into
the fray which could lead to the night
king killing and converting a second or
even a third dragon they're playing
defense and smartly hiding behind this
ring of fire Theon pledges to protect
bran with the Ironborn which brings the
on full circle from when he tried to
overtake Winterfell and force brandy
yield in season two
I'm taking your castle shield Tyrion
hangs back to pick brans brain you know
stump the stump tearing this returning
to what has always been the source of
his power
knowledged cleverness and hopefully the
new insights he gains from bran will
give them a new purpose so what secrets
did bran in part on Tyrion perhaps the
nature of the knight Kings origin with
the children of the forest plunging
dragon class into the heart of a man at
a weirwood tree setting up syrian maybe
to help bran lure the knight King back
into a parallel set up to try to end him
or maybe Jon's true identity giving
Tyrion greater cause to make sure Jon
makes it out of this battle alive even
if it's a Daenerys his expense or
perhaps Tyrion learned the strange
nature of brand's perception of time
other historical events that bran might
have influence beyond Hodor like turning
the Mad King mad or simply maybe Tyrion
just learned for bran exactly how
disastrous this Battle of Winterfell
will be for them because the next thing
we see Tyrion what's he doing drinking
he drinks because he knows things
Jaime joins him at the hearth along with
Brienne Podrick Davos and tormund
bringing some solid comic relief calling
Jamie King killer and not Kingslayer and
he tells everyone this TMI story about
killing a giant when he was 10 then
climbing into bed with a giant wife
breastfeeding from her for three months
all while chugging from this Big Horn of
milk this could just be another campfire
story from torment when we're back in
season 4 similarly before battle torment
cheered everyone up with this story of
betting a bear found this job but she
knew how to use
nice down below oh she was no ordinary
Beast later Tyrion tells them I think we
might live his argument rests on this
particular group's ability to somehow
survive many bloody battles but he might
actually be operating with some
knowledge gained from brand about who
will and who won't survive the coming
battle just something to check back in
on after next episode this leads to a
conversation about brands title Brienne
claims to not want to be a knight but a
quick glance at Patrick reminds us that
this isn't true she has been craving
knighthood since we first met her so as
a way to thank Brienne for her loyalty
and honestly reward her for being the
most honorable knight in spirit on this
show
Jaime annoys Brienne as a knight in the
name of the warrior the charger to be
brave the name of the Father
I charge you to be just the name of the
mother I charge you to defend the
innocent Jaime proclaims her sir Brienne
of Tarth a knight of the Seven Kingdoms
stating this episode's title and
reminding us of the ways Brienne has
already met all of these charges she
showed the Warriors bravery and fighting
the Hound and in many other fights she
showed the father's justice and
defending Jaime in this episode and she
showed the mothers defense of the
innocent and rescuing Sansa and trying
to protect aria now there's a further
interesting reference in Jaime's vows
here that I want to explain before I get
to that this video was sponsored by
expressvpn a VPN allows you to browse
the internet with privacy without things
like ad companies or hackers spyware any
of that stuff tracking your data
secretly filtering your Internet
experience Express me being masks your
IP address to make sure you aren't being
monitored so you can have that peace of
mind you can live life knowing no one's
peeping on you personally I use Express
VPN because you know when I'm
researching some of the dark gory
history behind Game of Thrones
I don't want third parties thinking I'm
too into that stuff on some weird
personal level I mean I am but that's
none of their damn business expressvpn
is the fastest VPN on the market and the
number one VPN service rated by
TechRadar and if you're in a different
country which many of our Game of
Thrones fans who follow us are you might
not be able to access everything on
Netflix and YouTube other streaming
services that you want to but thanks to
express VPN you can avoid those weird
restrictions and you can just watch
everything that you want to normally the
way the Internet should be wherever you
are expressly being lets you securely
stream or download content from anywhere
anytime it's less than $7 a month with a
30-day money-back guarantee take back
your internet privacy today and find out
how you can get three months free by
clicking on the link in the description
box expressvpn comm slash new rock stars
that's exp ress VPN comm slash new rock
stars for three months free with the
one-year package visit expressvpn comm
slash new rock stars to learn more take
back here Internet privacy today
okay back to Jamie a night of the Seven
Kingdoms is also the name of George RR
Martin's Dunkin egg series following the
young egg on the fifth and Duncan the
tall a famous night whom george RR
martin has more or less confirmed that
Brienne of Tarth directly descended from
so by repeating these sacred vows while
laying his sword on Briand shoulders
Jamie is not only realigning the twin
swords of Ned Stark's ice he's renewing
his vows of the night the vows he broke
by slaying the Mad King and I just love
the way this plays is a sweet secret
exchanging of vows on the eve of battle
similar to the way Will Smith and vivica
exchanged vows on the eve of
annihilation an Independence Day facing
an enemy that they also intended to give
a cold infecting the central hub and
wait for the drones to die out meanwhile
we catch up with the ways all the other
characters spend their last nights on
earth for gray were men with Sunday it's
a promise to retire to the beaches of
not Hasan Dee's home island great worm
promises to bring her there but assuming
these lovers are doomed
perhaps it will just be her body that he
brings there John meets with his
brothers of the Nights Watch and his
direwolf ghost woof
finally reappearing despite his absence
all of last season and says now I watch
speaking as the three brothers remember
their brothers who died like gran and
pip and gaze out over the battlements
frame deliberately to evoke their watch
on the capital w wall Aria initially
checks some of the hound and beric
Dondarrion revealing that he too is no
longer on her kill list and barrack and
always the cleric perceives this battle
as part of the destiny laid out by the
Lord of lights this is his moment but
the hounds hilarious dismissed over this
whole thing suggests that at least from
the show's perspective this battle might
not explore the prophecies of azor Ahai
that deeply it is worth remembering that
john was freakin resurrected with the
power of the Lord of Light so unless the
show plans on just leaving that
unexplained altogether if it's not
addressed in this battle lady Melisandre
must
have some splaining to do before the
final episode Aria ditches ezel dragon
jury whereas before their conversation
was all about death this later scene
embraces life Arya's entire demeanor
changes when ginjury tells her I'm above
birth pains busted and Aria is like yes
please and instead of asking Gendry how
many White Walkers he's killed this
seemed that the number she wants to know
is the women he's knighted and she wants
to Knight him only to know what this
feels like on the night before she might
die and yes this is a longtime companion
she wants beg to come with her to
Winterfell
I can be your family it would be much
fun
you'd be milady and now the union of
these two pays off the promise made by
ginjuries father in the first episode of
the series I have a son you have a
daughter well join our houses Aria
disrobes relax
revealing scars on her side presumably
these were given to her by the way fan
Braavos even if those wounds were in
slightly different spots
I just think ginjuries recognition of
these scars is meant to mirror Daenerys
seen John scars shortly before they rock
the boat in both cases these scars show
that this character is a completely
changed person from where they started
and that this person possesses an inner
power that their partner doesn't truly
appreciate House Mormont briefly reunite
with Lady Lyanna Mormont barking at her
cousin that she insists on fighting pan
she's probably safer out of the crypts
anyway and Sam gives Jorah his Tarly
family Valyrian steel sword hearts Bane
bringing up jours father G or Mormont
who is a father figure to Sam and John
at the wall Jorah gave Joris birthright
family's sword Longclaw to John so now
Sam is rebalancing the scales by
rearming this night with Valyrian steel
which he will wield engineers memory
then back at the hearth Podrick sings
high in the halls of the Kings who are
gone Jenny would dance with her go this
song is called Jenny song or Jenny of
old stones if first came up and George
are Martin's a Storm of Swords Lorenson
machine actually covered it in episodes
closing credits 10 able stones was a
strange and lovely girl from the
Riverlands who famously claimed to have
been descended from the children of the
forest the maesters of the Citadel
actually just reminded us of this last
season it brings to mind work
the charlatans who claimed descent from
the suitors of the sorrows yeah those
old masters are forced Sam there's that
better than anyone because these idiots
were equally skeptical of the three-eyed
Raven the White Walkers exist since the
wall ever falling so if they're wrong
about all that stuff they might also
have been wrong about Jenny of old
stones who could have been connected to
the children of the forest okay anyway
the important part is that Jenny and
Prince Duncan Targaryen were lovers and
Prince Duncan gave up his crown for her
this might connect to John a similar
Targaryen prince who seems willing to
give up his crown for his love for Danny
this song Jenny of old stones was a
favorite of Jenny's old friend a woods
witch called the ghost of high Hertz
rumored to actually be one of the
children of the forest herself Jenny
brought this witch to court where she
prophesied the prince that was promised
would come from the bloodline of the Mad
King and raela Targaryen Danny's parents
and Jon's grandparents and in the books
the ghost of high heart was right about
pretty much everything else she
predicted but anyway this ghost of my
heart loves this song about Jenny and in
the books we all never hear the first
line but now the show's writers build
out the rest of the lyrics they describe
Jenny dancing with ghosts than the Hall
of Kings ones whose names she couldn't
remember to spin away all of her sorrow
and pain these lyrics are probably
referencing the tragedy of summerhall
mysterious fire that swept through the
Targaryen pleasure home in Dorne it
killed both King Aegon v answer Duncan
the tall is Kingsguard
these are Duncan egg from the books but
much older also Brienne's ancestor
dunked the tall but this fire also
killed Prince Duncan who was Jenny's
lover and this idea of forgetting those
who are lost also evokes what bran and
Sam were talking about earlier with
history that forgetting a name and
history being erased is really the
ultimate form of death now it was
rumored that this Jenny song was
actually written by Rhaegar Targaryen
Maris's brother John's father who
famously loved to sing and famously sang
a song of attorney of Harrenhal that
made Lyanna stark John's mother weep and
presumably fall in love with him leading
to John's conception Dany even reminds
us of Rhaegar love of singing
immediately after this everyone told me
he was decent and kind he liked to sing
so essentially Patrick might be singing
the exact soundtrack to Rhaegar sperm
Duncan on Liana's egg and giving us egg
John pod singing this song follows the
tradition of
pre-battle shanties like Braun's singing
the rains of castamere with Lancer
soldiers before Blackwater or the men
and jaws singing show me the way to go
home and actually listen to the first
four notes of Podrick songs the composer
jadi actually used the same notes from
the melody of Pippins pre-battle song
The Edge of Night in Lord of the Rings
Return of the King mm-hmm behind and
this whole montage with pod singing over
it appears to be a direct homage to
Return of the King which played over a
similarly bleak sequence intercutting
among the charging soldiers the orc
archers and those away from the conflict
apparently next episode will be based
very much on the Battle of Helm's Deep
from Lord of the Rings the second movie
the two towers but more on that next
week but this montage here shows us all
the characters including Aria and Gendry
post-coitus Aria gazes away blankly
perhaps suggesting that she will always
feel like The Stranger alienated from
society and really never feeling the
true connection of family Don finally
tells Daenerys the truth in the crypts
which Daenerys initially denies and she
frames this as a source of conflict
between them if it were true it would
make you the lost male and I was joking
well you know what there doesn't
necessarily have to be conflict here
they could just marry if they really
loved each other in rulest Co monarchs
if they wanted before you Highlander
nerds saying there can only be one there
actually is some historical precedent
for coal monarchies past Targaryen
couples did sort of Co rule like King
Joe Harris and Queen Alice sane but we
have to look at it from Daenerys
perspective she emphasizes the word male
suggesting and adherence to old
patriarchal rules in as we saw with
Jaime 19 Brienne that old patriarchy
doesn't have to matter anymore
but ultimately Daenerys might not want
to share the Iron Throne it's not a love
seat and John might not fully trust her
judgment after learning of her wrath
against Sam's father and brother and her
near wrath against Jaime Lannister so
we'll just have to see if this conflict
complicates their cooperation in the
coming battle before they could even
discuss solution three horns blow which
according to Nights Watch protocol means
the sighting of White Walkers John gives
Dany a subtle nod and she departs
implying that at least for now whatever
strategy they had is still a go it's
worth noting that despite Daenerys
ordering Tyrion to go down
crepes Tyrion remains outside here on
the Battlement like he was at the Battle
of Blackwater so I'm guessing that
whatever knowledge bran shared with him
must have made Tyrion feel like he needs
to be outside for this fight or perhaps
Tyrion now knows that the dead of the
crypts will rise he doesn't want to be
anywhere near that
the final image of the episode shows the
White Walkers looming upon Winterfell
showing a row of at least a hundred
white Walker officers on horseback
Craster gave around a hundred of his
male babies to the night king for
transformation into White Walkers what
these could also be from other similar
donors that we don't know about across
the north over the ages the big thing
the note here is that the night king and
Viserion do not appear to be among them
I have speculated where they could be
like for example that whole theory that
the night king plans to target King's
Landing first converts Circe's forces
and the golden company and then returned
north which could pay off brand's vision
from season six of that shadow of a
dragon over King's Landing but now that
we know the night Kings real mission is
to erase human history there's actually
a pretty major source of Westeros T
history outside the three-eyed plant the
Citadel at Old Town the night King
torching that library would turn
historical records to ash turning it
into kind of a real world lost Library
of Alexandria that I've compared it to
in the past and make those skeptical
maesters over fill their chamber pots
this way the night King could take care
of other business across the continents
while avoiding the trap being set for
him by bran and John and the others and
he would kind of trick Jamie and the
rest with a misdirect just like Jamie
was fooled by a misdirect by Robb Stark
in his direwolf in the battle the
whispering wood which was brought up
this episode this final hour before the
battle is titled a night of the Seven
Kingdoms a nod to Brienne's anointing as
a knight and to Jamie Lannister a night
at the Seven Kingdoms implies a warrior
defending the whole realms of men over
one particular faction anointed Knights
like Sir Jaime Lannister sir Brienne of
Tarth ser jorah mormont sir Davos
Seaworth
and technically Sir Sandor Clegane since
he was briefly part of the Kingsguard
though he hates knighthood and entitles
all of these Knights are Manning these
front lines against the other night the
long night the night King Brienne of
Tarth
in formal knighthood tells us that these
characters can be deserving of
knighthood despite not meeting all the
traditional qualifications so I think
that we can look at all of these
warriors they seem this state
against death to protect the realm as
Knights of the Seven Kingdoms but which
of these Knights is most likely to die
in the battle comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at da boss and if you happen to
live in the LA area come check out my
live comedy show darkest timeline comedy
on May 3rd and every first Friday there
after last show sold out so you got to
get your tickets early friend thank you
for watching and as grossest Orman's
story was just be grateful you won't
ever have to actually see it in your
head like bran does
[Music]